the airspace above the nation's capital
and the area surrounding Washington DC
is the most restricted in the United
States the US Coast Guard is responsible
for intercepting any potential threats
that may appear in the sky only on CBS
this morning we spent an afternoon
riding with the unit that responds at a
moment's notice
to protect the DC airspace Jeff Pegues
is at a Coast Guard hangar at Reagan
National Airport Jeff good morning good
morning we are live on the tarmac here
at Reagan National Airport this is home
to the Coast Guard's blackjack unit and
that is one of the 865 dolphin
helicopters that they use to patrol the
skies especially if they see that an
unidentified aircraft is pierced
Washington's restricted airspace that
siren is the u.s. Coast Guard's call to
action
these helicopter crews have a matter of
minutes to get into the air and
intercept a plane that is breached
restricted airspace over Washington DC
it could be anything we want to give the
air as quickly as we can to determine if
it is a threat commander Zachary
Matthews says on average his unit chases
an aircraft a few times a week what is
the most challenging part of the job
you're scrambling out of here to fly
directly at an aircraft to intercept
them sometimes in the dark there are two
restricted flight zones around DC a
30-mile radius and then a severely
restricted 15 mile ring encircling the
white house any aircraft in this area
must be known to and communicating with
air traffic control if not Coast Guard
crews are scrambled to challenge the
plane and force it out of the airspace
[Music]
we flew on a training mission just south
of Washington our target a plane deemed
a possible threat Coast Guard helicopter
drops down within feet of the plane and
flashes warning signs all to get the
pilots attention the Coast Guard crew
reports what it sees two North American
Aerospace Defense Command or NORAD in
this case the training aircraft comply
hunter made the run
[Music]
the air intercept mission is very
challenging there's a lot of
communication so there's a very short
timeframe which a lot of stuff happened
in 1994 before the flight restrictions
were put in place a man piloting a
stolen plane crashed on the South Lawn
of the White House then on 9/11
terrorists crashed a 757 into the
Pentagon
it forced US officials to reimagine how
to protect Washington from airborne
threats those plans were again put to
the test in 2015 what a man landed a
gyrocopter on the Capitol Hill lawn US
officials acknowledged failures in that
case and the Coast Guard admits that
their job in the skies relies on its air
man and women being able to adjust what
is the most important attribute that you
look for agility to be nimble you never
know what you're going to see once you
get airborne the helicopters are not
armed
so if directions aren't followed NORAD
could scramble Air Force jets to
neutralize a threat it is one scenario
that they haven't seen yet but that's
what they trained for we have to bring
our a-game we have to be 100% ready at
all times and the men and women of this
unit I can tell you are always ready and
drones have become the latest potential
threat the Coast Guard and its
helicopters have to factor into their
flight plans and because drone
technology is still evolving the Coast
Guard has to learn and evolve to counter
that threat Nora
Wow incredible view there Jeff thank you
so much and Gail you talked about the
drones more I am so worried about the
drums you don't want to call it into
existence but I really do feel it's an
accident waiting to happen it scares me
when you're around certainly helicopters
airplanes I'm very worried about it but
I love Jeff's piece it just shows all
the preparation that goes imagine having
a job we have to be 100% ready at all
times
yeah Coast Guard they do amazing work
amazing work they do